julian assange could soon be extradited
to the United States after being
arrested this morning he had been holed
up in the Ecuadorian Embassy in London
for almost seven years before being
evicted dramatic video showing the
bearded WikiLeaks founder shouting as he
was being hauled away
the DOJ charging him with conspiracy to
help former Army Intelligence analyst
Chelsea Manning hack into the Pentagon's
computers to steal information Assange
is attorneys are vowing to fight the
extradition and saying it's a crackdown
on the Free Press this sets a dangerous
precedent for all media organizations
and journalists in Europe and elsewhere
around the world this precedent means
that any journalist can be extradited
for prosecution in the United States for
having published truthful information
about the United States Edward Snowden
the former security contractor who
leaked classified information about
America's surveillance program is
calling Assange's arrest quote a dark
moment for press freedom other reaction
also pouring in if you believe in
national security if you believe in the
safety of the United States he's a
villain in my opinion Julian Assange is
a hero he will probably be extradited
here we will see the indictment and
we'll probably have a show tried I do
not regard him as a hero just I think
it's about time Julian Assange has put
American lives at risk I'm glad that the
wheels of justice are finally turning
when it comes to mr. Assange I've never
been a fan I think what he did was a
despicable and dangerous and president
Trump was also asked about it earlier I
know nothing about WikiLeaks it's not my
thing
and I know there was something having to
do with Julian massage I've been seeing
what's happened with Assange and that
will be a determination I would imagine
mostly by the Attorney General
all right well we'll get to that in a
second but but people's opinions Greg of
Julian Assange have really changed over
the years at first the Democrats loved
him and they hated him
where do they stand now well here's the
deal I email Dana and our producer Megan
this morning wasn't about 9:00 a.m. and
I said I don't want to do this story
because I can't even remember how I feel
about jelly in his eyes because we were
when the fight began I guess this
must've been five oh well but I've been
writing what are you I can't tell you
how I feel about Asajj and I don't think
most of America even remembers because
the last three to four years has been
turned upside down every every ideology
every side every team sport has been
somehow mixed up and changed so I can't
I can't tell you how I feel but I will
find an argument in this so people that
are upset about this arrest are saying
this is an attack on journalism a dark
day on journalism if that is true then
you could never arrest anybody hacking
into your computer or maybe even
breaking into your apartment let's say
my assistant goes into my computer and
takes all of my emails right it doesn't
matter if there's good stuff in there or
bad stuff she is stealing my property
let's say if she ships that over to the
Washington Post and they have a story
about me running this amazing drug ring
out of my office not true but the point
is she has broken the law now if you
want to commit German journalism and
there's a risk of breaking the law then
fine you got to pay the price but if
somebody is taking something that
belongs to you in this case that's what
the charges is breaking into a State
Department computer and stealing if
somebody comes in and is taking my
emails that is theft
can you call theft journalism I don't
think you can there is no reporting in
theft right it's only a story if they
find something in your emails but that's
not journalism that is hacking and
that's my theory that is a great theory
all right maybe not one of many great
theories from you Greg
Dana the Obama administration didn't
charge Assange with what he's now being
charged with that people are saying well
why was it not illegal then but now it
is no I think it's because a couple
things my my opinion about Assange has
never changed you had is not about
tribalism like I'm Team America that
what he did he don't even American like
how does he get First Amendment
protections the curtain for journalism
see now I remember that way remember the
shows we did
it was bad I mean you were yes but I was
right yeah okay so that is very
interesting so one of the things about
the Obama administration's that there
stymie one there were actual
intelligence harms that were done
diplomatic harms that resulted from that
huge then you had the whole thing about
Bradley Manning's transformation now
Chelsea Manning there's all that Obama
pardons her at the end or commutes her
sentence right there and then these
people take on these mythical hair that
like their heroes well once I hear old
ones a heroine now I guess but the Obama
administration couldn't figure out how
to charge him without him being able to
get journalistic protection right what I
think is pretty amazing and the Trump
administration should be like look at us
we figured it out because they were the
ones I don't know whether through
additional investigation maybe we'll
find this out but they were the ones to
say this is not a First Amendment claim
this is a national security threat this
was a this was theft and for the rest of
these people like up they want all of
our information to be open and free to
everybody except for they howl about
Internet companies and privacy it's a
bizarre it is bizarre
speaking of bizarre one look great today
after a big birthday night out I'm sure
oh yeah that was me it seems like the
left especially in the media are trying
to link President Trump with Julian
Assange now and they're pulling all
these tapes I guess from the campaign
when the president was saying WikiLeaks
I can't wait to read what they said and
and I guess that's the new collusion
perhaps is that it no I think you know
he was encouraging them and then today
when he was entry says WikiLeaks I know
nothing about WikiLeaks I mean it's so
obviously wrongheaded and he's just
trying to avoid any connection but you
know let's leave that alone I mean
that's politics right but I'm very
interested in this story because it's
evident that the first the Ecuadorians
threw him out and they say he was not a
good tenant their government correct so
I don't I didn't want to get on but
clearly the first step is that they had
been granting him asylum by holding him
in that embassy and once he's out then
he's subject to possible extradition and
that's where now the US
arge is very careful it doesn't get into
the arguments that greg and dana been
going through about journalism not
journalism it simply says you work a
co-conspirator in terms of helping
Chelsea Manning to hack into our Defense
Department computers that's clearly
illegal that's their strongest stand and
that's why I think he can be then
extradited and he's likely to lose that
case in my opinion when you ask me
though I mean you know I got hurt by
WikiLeaks because I lost my cellphone
and I was awakened in Las Vegas after it
was hacked and they had my cell phone
and I just it just very unpleasant I got
to use that excuse once too but I gotta
say that I think there's a big answering
the phone on-air do you remember that I
remember you answer no in fact Dana
afterwards people who you know we're
still calling number four I got rid of
it and they'd say can I talk to grant
what about me what am I chopped liver
here no but I got to say serious news
organizations you well you can be handed
you could walk in and say hey Juan
here's the Pentagon Papers and I'll say
well let me see it and I'll you know but
it's not me telling you here's how you
go get the pen here's how to break the
law write the allegation was he was
trying to crack the passwords in order
to infiltrate the State Department
system and amazing how he was able to
stay in the embassy for seven years
there must have been a lot of behind the
scenes dealings between the Ecuadorians
and the British in the US well no longer
and you guys all of your your feelings
your inclinations that are totally
correct so legally think of it as a
brilliant strategy frankly that the US
DOJ has undergone at this point because
their burden of proof on this is so low
it's so clear it's so simple
you are right it has nothing to do with
what was stolen or what was published or
what was done it's you broke into the
house right so there's no defense beyond
that that even needs to be addressed at
this point the UK US extradition treaty
is such that right now at this point the
next step after this whole jumping bail
thing which we know he might face up to
a year in jail in the UK is that they
will the UK courts will review the
indict in the charging document and if
there is the requisite specificity that
goes to their level of acceptance then
they extradite him here
so as we know he also faces up to just
simply five years in prison and to me
that also is interesting we kind of
talked about this before the show that
the seven years of his self-imposed
exile and the wretched creature we saw
being brought out of the embassy today
he he was in a worse hell and worse
prison anticipating all of this and
worrying about it and freaking out then
frankly was about Pamela Anderson is
there one if there is then it's usually
five years however because he was
granted asylum by Ecuador to me it tolls
the statute of limitations and there is
no way that the US underwent all of this
in the grand jury proceedings last year
without having them know that they can
rely on that to toll it which means
deposit so I think the First Amendment
arguments are on the left people say
that he's a hero because you know but
turned out that he reveals some
information about the US government in
fact monitoring or surveilling American
citizens and we as Americans have a
right to know was the argument but this
is not about this this is about a guy
who was participating what I think was
an illegal breach of American security
also a villain on the left for the
Hillary Clinton and Podesta yeah why did
the New York Times and Washington Post
use that illegal information